7h ce matin la tension monte une
cinquantaine de personnes des défenseurs
du quartier mais aussi des migrants se
rassemblent devant l'une des maisons
menacées de destruction ils veulent les
réquisitionner mais des vigiles en
gardent l'entrée
on considère que ça sert à rien de les
détruire vu que les travaux de la zone 2
commenceront pas avant 2018 du coup
effectivement on a barricadé pour ce qui
est de cette maison et de l'autre maison
ça a été barricadée du coup là il ya
deux maisons guide qui sont en très bon
état
étant donné que rebsamen était prêt à
accueillir des migrants ici à dijon nous
on a envie que ces maisons soirée
occupée par les migrants
quelques instants plus tard des agents
d'edf arrive à la demande de la mairie
pour couper le courant des maisons les
manifestants les arrose alors pour les
empêcher de monter au pylône c'est à ce
moment que la situation dégénère les
vigiles utilise des gaz lacrymogènes
pour les repousser
notre journaliste est blessé des
affrontements ont lieu entre les deux
camps
après plusieurs minutes d'extrême
tension les vigiles repartent et les
manifestants parviennent à prendre
possession des deux maisons
finalement il est 9 heures quand le
quartier des lentillères retrouve un peu
de calme sur la chaussée les traces de
l'affrontement sont bien visibles de
leur côté les squatteurs remontent des
barricades tout autour des deux maisons
bien décidé à rester le plus longtemps
possible